[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young dad
who's experiencing burnout and he
doesn't know what that means to have
burnout and be a man we talked to a mom
who's struggling with their
five-year-old little one we talked to a
sister whose brother-in-law has screwed
up everything she doesn't know what to
do next stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time to dance kids this the dr john
dalone's show we talk about mental
health and relationships and
excitement and sad stuff and hard stuff
fun stuff
whatever's going on in your heart and
mind give me a call
[Music]
thirty two ninety 1-844-693-3291 it's
one eight four four six nine three three
two nine one leave a message kelly will
call you back or go to johndaloni.com
ask ask
and don't forget the conversation cards
how to be a human
so excited man they are awesome um they
are cards for
you and your romantic partner cards for
you and your kids
and cards
for
multi-generational
conversations
stocking stuffers
traveling
just sitting in the car when you're like
waiting in the pickup line at after
school and you don't know what to talk
to your kid about we designed these
guards man these are just so y'all can
begin to have conversations that don't
involve screens that don't involve
politics and nonsense and
shenanigans no tick tock videos
just how to have a conversation
they're so fun can't wait they're
selling like crazy i think we already
almost sold out of the first bunch like
it's awesome get em johndaloni.com
and you can click and buy the cards i'm
super excited about him get him get him
get him get him get him
save your families
that's probably a little bit over
overstated but it's cool
uh a little bit overstated
all right let's get right to the phones
let's go to connor in scottsdale hey z
what's up brother how are we doing
what's going on dr d pleasure to talk
with you man it's a pleasure to talk to
you brother how's it going
dude it's going really well first let me
start off with uh been a been a listener
since uh before day one remember the uh
the ramsey episode when he introduced
you as a personality and then how
excited it was to you starting a show so
big fan man thanks brother you are in
rare air there's only like
there's not a lot of you guys so thank
you so
much it
no problem
uh so want to get your thoughts and i'll
let you dig into it on burnout
um you know is is burnout a real thing
uh what are some of the i guess side
effects of it is it physical mental and
how do you know if you're experiencing
true burnout
man so yes
thousand percent it's real it's a
biochemical issue
uh i think sometimes it gets lumped into
a character issue or you're not tough
enough issue or things like that
but yes you can your body can get cooked
the best book i've ever ever ever read
seen heard about on this topic is by the
nygotsky sisters and i'll link to it in
the show notes it's called burnout
that's the name of the book
and they wrote it for women i've talked
to numerous men who find it incredibly
um
important as well and are valuable i
find it valuable as well but using their
framework which i love
um you can break down exhaust uh you can
break down burnout into a couple of
different things number one well let me
back out you're experiencing this is
that why you're asking
no blow on yeah okay okay so i'm going
to break this framework down but i want
to use you as the as the
case study okay
number one is this deep sense of
complete and utter exhaustion you open
your eyes in the morning and you're
tired
and somewhere about 7 30 8 30 a.m you
start thinking about
dude in 10 more hours i can be right
back here
yeah
exactly
so walk me through it yeah exactly
um
i mean just to give you a very quick
back story um
you know my my entire life i've always
felt with the
that deep sense of like not feeling good
enough and not you know always needing
to prove myself which led into you know
being in competitive motorsports and
and kind of being put in that world of
um
i've heard you say it a couple times
that rough tough talk hard charger of
prove myself be stronger kill or be
killed kind of
mentality and
over the last five years you know i've
experienced a few
um i guess some would say a
life big life events you know um with my
becoming a new dad and then my
uh
my ex trying to take her life and then
changing jobs and changing careers and
being a single parent and you know
meeting uh
meeting my now
absolutely beyond epic wife
um and then
going through the crazy immigration
process
um get you know she's from a different
country and and kind of when you add all
this stuff on top of it along with this
you know
um
challenging
environment that we're in now with the
with culture
and and kind of just society of being
that all right
you know i'm the i'm the man of the
house and my wife's russian so she's
very uh
you gotta be a real man and
what i'm noticing is
the way i
personally the way i personally
react to stress is
be stronger work harder be better
and
the more stress it's put on me the
harder i want to work and the harder i
want to
you know provide and the harder i want
to push myself
to the point where i'm super blessed
with with a boss that's you know hey
work as many hours as you want which
that's a blessing and a curse because i
look at it and go you know yeah we're
we're walking through the baby steps and
you know we're we're in baby step 3b and
so i'm like
you know
gazelle intensity and so i'm you know i
turn around and and my mindset is be the
gazelle but then
you've used the metaphor a couple times
that the gazelle gets tired
and
my mindset is how do you turn around as
a gazelle and grab the lion you know by
the throat and be like
how do you be better and
it's kind of it just all led up to
when i contacted you i've talked to
different
you know pastors and counselors
and everything and listening to your
show like man i would love to get
you know your
your tips and tricks
and your insight into it because a few
weeks ago i think the last
i'd say the last five years kind of all
just hit like i wasn't sick
but just just moving and getting out of
bed just it just wasn't happening yeah
could just so here's
so burnout
is when your body says
dude i'm out
at some point your body says
we've
this is as much as i got right now
and we can
make it it you might get the flu you
might get sick you might get cancer you
might do any number of things
but at some point the alarms have been
ringing for long enough that your body
finally says it's like dude it's like
it's like uh
driving your car and never changing the
oil
and then someone's saying dude you got
to pull over and change the oil and
you're like no bro you've got to drive
faster drive faster
and like okay dude but like the light's
blinking on the dash and you just say
drive faster at some point your car
engine just melts together and the
if you don't do maintenance on the car
just quit running
and so yeah burnout you you just me and
you just walked through
the entire
bricks in the backpack
like you were born into a story
into a culture that said you're not a
human being you're a human doing
you are what you accomplish so
accomplish well
and you found some accomplishment you
found some esteem which is awesome which
is great in motorsports which revs your
body up all day every day
and
you almost die every day proving
yourself literally
and then you move on to all those
different traumas and so yeah dude
there's just a point when your body just
goes brother i'm i if you're not gonna
stop i'm gonna stop us
and then it all comes crashing down by
the way you gotta now you've got a new
culture that you are
um
connecting with that has a picture of
what masculinity looks like and what
strength looks like and all that
so
it sounds like you're tired man
of all of it so let me
um
yes yes and no
um
how
so with you know
without going into obviously we could we
could
i would love to and we could talk for
hours and hours and hours
how
when your body says
you know chemically enough enough the
engine oil is gone the engine's you know
dead
you've pushed so hard that you know and
and i can get all of that you know i get
pacing yourself in a long distance race
and taking care of the vehicle and
everything like that but how do you
fight the
when the engine
stops when you burn out the feelings of
you're not good enough be stronger you
shouldn't burn out you're a failure
because you're sleeping in bed all day
long you know there's male figures in my
life that the joke was
growing up and that's all i ever saw was
you know i only worked a half day at my
job what we do with the other 12 hours
is up to us yeah
no and so it's and that's that's that's
a voice of someone who's cooked
so my hope for everybody is you never
fully get there
because it's hard to come back
it's hard how do you come back
you got to be really intentional and
often people come back in rehab or they
come back in divorce court or they come
back and their children are filing for
emancipation
usually just got fired and they got to
figure out a new career coming back can
be hard it happens every single day
that's why i do the show
everybody everybody can come back
i believe that all my my soul i wouldn't
be doing this
um but it's hard
so i want you to take take the engine
metaphor away and i want to give you
another metaphor that i think is going
to be better
so imagine you know anything about
plumbing at all
absolutely okay so
um
you've got like a clog
you can run in your pipes and you know
your sink starts backing up you can run
to the hardware store and grab a bottle
of drano dump it in there and chances
are it will it will at least let that
thing drain
and it's bad for your pipes it's bad for
everything but it's bad for the your
sewer system it's bad for everything but
it will clear clear that that that clog
if every morning you woke up and just
dumped drano into your into your sink
every day
in short order it would eat through the
pipes it would destroy everything
and so i want you to think about that
when it comes to your body's stress
response
our stress response is still ancient
technology it is running on
um
hey there's a tiger and it's going to
try to eat us and i got to get away or i
got to kill it or it's going to kill me
and
whenever you walk through a life
thinking i'm not good enough or i just
screwed that up or i should have done
this that's got to be better i got to
get done faster i got to work more i got
to do more
all the time your body just has a few
responses to that and it is a cortisol
and adrenaline and stress hormones over
and over and over and over
and that's like dumping drano and then
to solve that problem you hop on a
motorbike and drive 95 miles an hour and
try not to die
and it's like well we're back in it
again and then you are in a marriage
that has fallen apart and you're back in
it again and a home becomes a place
that's not safe
so you leave a bear cave and go home and
there's a tiger on your couch
and then and then and then and then
and then you see your aunts and uncles
or your dad or your granddad
who just most of your memories are them
sitting on the couch
because their bodies say screw you man
or they're
they're seven tall boys into every
single day of their life
because beer turns the alarms down a
little bit it works for a while until it
kills you
or you just get cooked
and then meth and coke and all and 17
red bulls it will speed you up to get
through a day and then you collapse and
do it again the next day and do it again
the next day
and so what i want you to do is i want
you to back up and stop putting drano in
the sink
and so
i want you to think of burnout as this
is from the nagaski sisters i love it it
is the result of unfinished business you
haven't completed the stress cycle you
spun up some stress in your life and you
haven't completed it
you got to let that thing cycle through
which is why
a break isn't um
a reward a break is an essential part of
a hard day
relationships being with people going
for walks exercise eating right sleeping
those are not
things that you add on to your life
those are core principles that you have
to have
you have to have days of the week that
you take off
if you are going to be gazelle intense
it's got gotta be short order you gotta
crush it crush it crush it with a i can
do this for three years and that is it
and then i've got to stop putting drano
in that drain for a season
and
you have to deal with those bricks in
your backpack brother those stories you
carrying around with you
and here's how i do it i'll tell you how
exactly how i do it because i've got
those same ones in my bag
okay
i have a small little black
um journal and what i'm about to tell
you sounds cheesy and stupid don't let
your buddy see it but actually i don't
care cause we need to change the picture
of what masculinity even looks like
um
and it's a stories journal that i carry
with me
and i'll write it down and now i've been
doing it so long now that it's i don't
have to write it down all the time
because now i can spin it out pretty
quick out of my head but that
you should have i write that down
i can't believe you didn't i write that
down
you just need to suck it up and man up i
write that down
and i look at it i literally will extend
my arm i talked about this in a recent
show i will extend my arm at arm's
length and i will look at it jocko calls
that detachment
michael singer calls that mindfulness
you can call it whatever you want
whether you're a navy seal or you're a
um like a guru i don't care
you got to get some space from that
thought and then demand evidence is that
true
and that's the magic brother right there
am i the worst dad the answer is no
am i a crappy man no
does manning up mean
um that i don't get to sleep no
that's foolish it's nonsense look around
brother all men are dying young diseases
of despair they're all addicts and
it's crazy when you look across the
culture
right it's insane yeah absolutely we
need a generation of men to take care of
themselves now hear me say not work real
you guys still work your butt off be
really really
um
uh
set high goals man
be really ambitious
and no not a problem here okay but look
set those high goals be ambitious and
know that ambition is not gonna save you
it's not gonna make everything better
there is no dollar amount that's gonna
make you go now
i'm worthy that doesn't exist
it's both and
be ambitious have high goals
and know
what's gonna
make your heart still
is a great marriage
is kids that love being around their dad
those moments when you're just fishing
and everything's quiet and you're not
catching anything and you think
this is right
those are the things that heal you
not more money and more accomplishments
and more titles and more straps on the
wall
and so it's both and and you we live in
a culture that tells you either or and
this is why i think most people are
exhausted
like you just need to sit at home and
the government will mail you checks
that's ridiculous we have purpose we are
have we are designed to contribute
as my friend ken coleman says you got to
have a purpose you got to get we are
designed to work
and that work in and of itself won't
heal you it's both and
and so what does that mean you've got to
re-examine your meaning why are you
doing what you're doing
do you have that
do i absolutely why are you getting up
every day connor
i want to provide a better you know life
for no that's external not only that's
external what about you
what do you want
i i don't have that it's it's every
every reason i have is external okay
there's zero internal reasons because
then it gets into a whole nother topic
of i feel selfish if i have too many
internal reasons and that's hey so
that's a story you write down i'm
selfish for taking care of me bullcrap
i'm selfish for changing the oil in my
car what
i'm selfish for uh putting wiper fluid
in my car what
that doesn't even make sense
and i'm not getting onto you i'm getting
onto our culture here
and so that's a story you write down and
you hold it out and go no that's
nonsense i have to take care of conor
otherwise conor can't take care of
anybody else
but so many men their identity is what
they provide for other people
and i need men to start looking in the
mirror and saying what do i need
how can i contribute to my well-being so
that i can then do these other things
that the world needs us so desperately
to be doing
so you've got to re-examine meaning
you got to move your body and discharge
this energy
okay
you have to have a regular practice of
exercise of moving your body up doing
something going for walks and if you
have a high high stress job if you're
still running motocross you're still
doing high stuff then i want you to lift
weights and go for walks
not dump a marathon on top of all that
stuff because there's a point when that
stress just becomes toxic it just eats
your it just eats your body inside out
okay and then the third one is human
connection
sleep you gotta have good relationships
and i recommend i know you love your
wife's a saint and angel you gotta have
male buddies do you have that
um none my age all
significantly older than me just because
i love mentors so i no i don't really
have any friends my exact age so what
i've learned from myself
is that we often have older male mentors
because it gives us a reason to have a
relationship
we can say we're learning something
and because we don't think we're worthy
of just having a regular relationship
and so your goal is your your new
challenge is to get male friends your
age and do stuff
go fishing fix bikes mow each other's
yards
just grab a beer and laugh and play
poker i don't care what it is
and if at all possible bring your kid
along too so that he has a picture in
his head of what friendship looks like
because you don't have that
you have a picture of men going home and
just sitting on the couch and staring
off into space
and then the final thing was i want you
to start
being creative do you have a hobby at
all brother
oh yeah okay i want you to continue
that's that's tough because my hobby is
my job so it's ah okay then you gotta
get something else you gotta get
something else it's hard
because i know a lot of mechanics
they're mechanics and they go home and
they spend the next four hours working
on their car you know what i say
i would love to see you do something
else
to get creative and expand your mind but
i also don't want to take away your art
and i get that so i don't know what you
do for a living but i get that and get
messy
if you are a cop and then you go home
and try to solve crimes at night you're
gonna you're gonna melt your brain
if you're a plumber and then for
at night time your your
your hobby is more plumbing you're gonna
you can just make yourself bonkers
absolutely so
you gotta have a hobby where you can be
creative and creativity can be cooking
it can be
re go take dancing classes go take learn
guitar i don't care dude be a poet i
don't care what it is go hunting but you
got to find some create creative outlets
and then i want you to start a gratitude
journal
every day of your life i want you to
wake up and write down five things
you're grateful for i got my gratitude
journal in my bag too i carry two
journals with me i do
every day of my life i'm grateful for
this and over
a month two months six months a year
you're gonna change your body chemistry
through gratitude and there's a billion
studies for that
um check out that book um burnout
i wanna redefine what it looks like to
be a
man we're gonna create a third path
i do need you to lift weights i need you
to be strong i need you to be there for
your community and
i need you to have relationships and
friends and hobbies i need you to look
in the mirror and say i can't help
others be well if i'm not well
you got to start with you you got to put
your oxygen mask on first
and if you sleep and take care of your
body then you can show up when the world
needs strong arms
if you are creative and well then you
can help solve some of these vexing
challenges that are that we're all
wrestling with
[Music]
don't sit at home and collect checks and
don't step into a slim jim it's both
you got to go work and you got to find
meaning you got gotta find purpose and
you gotta rest and change the oil
gotta stop dumping drano down the sink
we'll be right back on the doctor john
ellen show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance i can't get off work and time
to go see somebody and it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john doloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com slash deloney
all right what's up let's talk to rosie
in cordeline
what's up rosie
hi how are you
oh i'm good
how about you i'm good you are on the
show
all right all right so what's up how can
i help
so um
my husband and i decided to uh
that i should stay home with our
five-year-old
and i've been doing that since june and
i feel like i stuck at it like i feel
like a failure
and that's what i want to talk about
[Laughter]
well thanks for that softball appreciate
that rosie
so why did y'all
y'all the way you announced that
the way you told me that was that your
husband wanted you to stay at home and
you all talked about it and now you're
staying at home am i wrong there
um
yeah we decided together
i deal with that
i i think that's my idea okay all right
the way you presented that sunday i
usually have the ideas
yes okay
so
um
why did you want to stay home
um
well
i want to stay home because um
i used to be able to take my son to work
with me
when i worked in child care
and when
that business was closing
um
there just didn't seem like
being in the business we knew that there
was no one that we would trust with our
son
okay yes
so you don't trust anybody with your son
and so
you want to stay at home
and be with him you like being around
him
yeah mostly okay
and so here's the death spiral i just
hear professional woman after
professional woman after young mother
get involved in
there is no way to win
and if you're at work you should be at
home oh my gosh you just work and leave
your kid with somebody all day
and then if you're at home
it is
i don't like my kid all the time and as
soon as i have that thought like oh my
gosh if you wipe your own butt crack
then i feel guilty that i even said that
because this is my baby and i'm a
terrible mom
or if i just love wiping butt cracks all
day people are like are you serious you
just stay at home like what else what
are you contributing
like your husband just earns all the
like seriously
there's this
never-ending cycle of guilt
do you experience any of that
um
not really that mostly like
um
i thought that i i think i should be
doing better at
um keeping the house clean like
it's just always a mess and it seems
like if i'm home all day
it should be clean like that was my
expectation was so you know when i was
working 12 hours a day it was like i
have no time to clean the house whose
story is that i'm home all day is it
your story or your husband's story
mine okay then so i'm just gonna ask you
simple questions so then
why don't you clean the house
um
i
don't know like sometimes it seems like
sometimes it seems like we run out of
time like we're not just home all day
like we we go places and then by the
time we get home it's like
time to eat dinner and then
after all that stuff is done in bedtime
then it's just
i don't know i get tired yeah
so i don't know that's why i asked
myself is like why am i not getting this
done like
i should be able to do it
have you made a
so much here
you're living in some pretty hard
pictures that you've created for
yourself you've drew drawn for yourself
you have a picture of what stay-at-home
motherhood should look like
and your picture isn't real
it seems like it for the people i know
in their curated social media worlds or
like i go to their house and it's clean
well maybe
and yeah there's two hands one is you've
created a myth you are not them you are
you and you're trying to live their
story
and you need to be to articulate what is
your story
and number two there is some discipline
involved here
yeah when you were going to work and you
were tired you still had to show up
you still had to do things at your job
you didn't want to do
or you were tired of doing but that was
your job and you were on the clock
and so there is seasons
i guess for every
stay-at-home parent forever
is
yeah i am exhausted and i got to do
laundry again and it just never stops
and oh good there's more dishes in this
they keep coming they grow in this sink
right it just never stops
and there's that part too where you just
have to do things that you don't want to
do or you're tired of doing
but to me it feels like there's
something deeper than that
that you thought this was going to be
different or easier or simpler or
it would just work out and it's not and
it's
weighing on you maybe i'm out to lunch
maybe it's not existential at all it's
just a matter of dude yeah no it's all
that
if you want to have a clean house have a
clean house but all of a sudden you look
up and it's 10 30 in the morning
have you done a
like uh
have you done like an honest assessment
of how much time you spend on social
media how much time you spend in front
of the tv how much time you spend
um emailing folks
like have you done an honest time
assessment
i've
been trying to like i'm not trying to
have you done an honest time
like to me an honest time assessment is
like i want a minute by a minute count
of like how did i spend my time so i've
been like looking for like how do i
track that because if i just have a
piece of paper i'm not gonna like
write down every single second so i've
been thinking about it so no i haven't
actually calculated the times but rosie
can i be honest there's something else
here what's the other what's the other
thing
the other thing is
what is it that you don't want to say
out loud say it
um
my child
has
adhd and odd
and i guess just like
sometimes it's such a war zone all day
that it's like
i guess i just feel like i need to treat
myself like
i'm so exhausted like i can't do
anything else
you need some help
is your home
chaotic
young
sometimes sometimes it's not
is your marriage okay
yeah
yeah my husband's amazing
has your
child always struggled with that
disconnect
because adhd odd those kind of things
are
generally challenges not always but
generally challenges with disconnection
with relational challenges
i thought we had
a pretty
good connection like all three of us and
then um
yeah like several months ago i don't
know like almost a year ago
it just seemed like his outrages were
just getting
more and more extreme like we couldn't
connect to him in those moments and so
have you taken him to a good play
therapist to see what's going on
we haven't found a good one we found
terrible ones like we were on a waiting
list for nine months and then we finally
get there and it was just
kind of a waste of time
why was it a waste of time
um
[Music]
because we just played we didn't do
anything
for like learning skills like that's a
kit
any play therapist for the first three
four five sessions is just simply going
to play with your kid because that's how
kids communicate through play that's
their language
yeah and if you're a parent and they may
not have done a good job setting it up
or you may be an impatient parent
which is you by the way um
just looking at play therapy can seem
insane
because a good play therapist is going
to try to learn the language of your
child
and learn what stories are they're
trying to connect to
it's hard
yeah you've got to give that some time
yeah
i guess when i say it seems like
a waste of time like
the person kind of just stopped back and
like watched the two of us play and like
i just felt like yes yes but you don't
like i guess just you didn't like these
instructions
yes
yes it's called non-directive play
therapy
it's exactly what it is well nobody told
me that because what they're trying to
do what are we doing here they are
trying to see how you engage with your
child
because here's why behavior is a
language
and when your kid has an outburst
they're trying to tell you something and
it's usually you don't see me
or i don't see you seeing me or i have
no boundaries or structure
or you spend so much time looking at a
screen i need you to see me
or even when you're with me you haven't
dealt with your own depression or
anxiety and i've you are with me
physically but you are not with me
spiritually mentally
and kids or
who it could be a thousand different
things
that's what a play therapist does is
just trying to read the the
communication patterns between a parent
and child
and i don't think you liked being
watched like that
it's probably unnerving
and in five or ten minutes you probably
got really bored playing with your kid
is that fair yeah and now
then you wonder
if you can't spend five or ten directed
minutes with your child
it doesn't surprise me that your child
is desperate for connection all over the
place
and so what i want you to not not as a
shame thing
it's just a set of skills
it's just like dude i don't know how to
hang drywall i've tried it's a it's a
mess i gotta learn how to do that if i
ever wanna to build a house
and so that's why you need some skills
you all need to learn new ways to
communicate but if you don't demonstrate
how you communicate then no one can help
you if you like a plumber can't just
like stand on your front yard and be
like well you just need to flush the
toilet and fix this part i gotta go in
there and look
and i'm just gonna sit there and flush
the toilet and listen and stuff like
that it's gonna be weird that's what we
gotta do
but it my guess is tell me i'm crazy
you are carrying some sort of shame
baggage that's heavy
or the last 24 months which nobody's
been good at
has just wrecked you
tell me i'm wrong if i'm wrong
i feel like i'm ashamed of my lack of
contribution there you go
and shame is a black hole
and kids get sucked into those things
you get sucked into those things
marriages get sucked into black holes
you sound tired
yeah
not tired like sleepy tired but tired
existentially exhausted
and so here's what here's what's on the
horizon for you
number one is kindergarten
you're gonna have a shift next year if
you choose to put your kid in school
and so you're gonna have an identity
shift you're gonna have a household
shift things are gonna be different so
you may be looking at six more months
seven more months before things shift
again
i want you to see value in rosie the way
i see valiant rosie
and you're worth
being well
and you're worth peace
and you're worth laughter and you're
worth a babysitter
and you're worth telling a five-year-old
here's our boundaries
and you're worth learning how to play
with your kid
not being annoyed by him you're worth
not being on your phone all the time
you're worth not comparing yourself to
the other people's houses you go to who
cares forget them
my house is messy but my house is more
fun than yours
that's what i'm saying people come to my
house all the time and i tell them
y'all are my friends i'm gonna clean up
for you but we're gonna have a time of
your life
we do clean up
relatively depends on who you are
it sounds like you're in a shame
comparison
spiral
and i would love love love rosie love to
see you
go talk to somebody and say i'm not okay
i'm tired
and i'm ashamed of my lack of
contribution but then when i'm
contributing i'm ashamed that i'm not
spending enough time with my son i'm
ashamed about how my son acts in my
house
i'm ashamed that i can't play 10 minutes
with my kid without getting bored and
then wanting to go do something else
i want you to take an honest time
assessment rosie on how you're spinning
in front of screens now just been
disconnected
i want you to be honest about learning
some new skills your kid needs that so
here's the question
that you gotta ask yourself
this is all the way this is right now
and there's a period at the end of the
sentence
the question you gotta ask yourself is
what are you gonna do tomorrow
what will be different tomorrow than
today
are you asking me now yeah
um what phone call we make tomorrow
well tomorrow i'm going to meet with
another mom who has her son has um
developmental disabilities as well so
we're going to be talking about it
together cool so when when you go meet
with that mom
i want you to tell tell her what you
told me
i'm ashamed of my lack of contribution
i don't know how to play with my kid for
more than five minutes without getting
bored can you help me with that
yeah
i want to better engage with my kid
and chances are
your kid feels plugged in then your
kid's brain says now i'm safe
and your kid's brain doesn't sh doesn't
fire off all the signals that are all
over creation
that manifests themselves in all sorts
of different whatever diagnostic
diagnostic labels want to stick on stuff
but almost every childhood challenge is
related to connection in some shape form
or fashion relational connection
some people ask me like hey my kids
struggle with anxiety my first thing is
fix your marriage make sure your
marriage is strong and good
the second thing is make sure you're
okay because kids absorb tension and
kids who struggle with adhd i'm one
generally grow up in homes of that are
got chaos
moms who have extreme stress or moms who
are struggling with identity challenges
who am i where am i
odds i mean similar the kids are
screaming for boundaries help help help
help help
show me boundaries whole boundaries love
me
and it's hard these these aren't
conversations about blame these are
conversations about tools conversations
about
um
strategies conversations about learning
new things and we all can learn new
things
i'm trying to do it every day
i'm proud of you for calling rosie
proud of you for loving that little boy
and
i want you to start loving rosie
be honest for the first time with that
mom tomorrow no showing no performances
no
just say hey i'm not doing okay
start with vulnerability there somebody
you trust
i recommend you call a counselor maybe
get back on that play therapy list and
give it a shot
let's start with vulnerability tomorrow
i'm proud of you
be right back on the doctor john along
show
y'all know there are lots of things that
make me nuts but one thing makes me more
nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
because you got an expert in a team who
have your back listen if you're about to
buy a home and make a big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right let's take one more
marie in des moines des moines iowa
what's up marie
hi dr john how are you remarkable how
are you
i'm well thank you good what's up
well
i have a brother-in-law who is currently
serving time for wire fraud oh good yes
oh good yeah yeah
you sound thrilled marie congratulations
yes i'm really tickled about it it's
great um
in reality i'm really really mad you
should be you should be pissed off
yes yeah and
my sister so his
wife has now finally hit that point
where she's not in you know
complete chaos of
i don't know when the next shoe is going
to drop yep so she is finally mad and i
am just trying
to figure out how i be supportive of her
but also
not just bash her husband because i know
the time comes when he gets out that
he's still a part of our family
and i still love him even though he made
a huge mistake but i'm really angry i
don't know how to support her
and forgive him and rebuild
relationships when that comes oh you're
awesome
you're awesome she's lucky to have you
as her sister all right so are you ready
for this
what's that that's like a song you all
ready for this
um
i'm not gonna do cartwheels across a
basketball court but
um here's a couple of key things and
you're already there just want to
reiterate them
never ever ever talk bad about him in
front of her
her story is about her
right and so
your story will be about you and you'll
need to go other places for that than
from her
what you don't want to do is have a
commiseration event where you all just
sit together and talk about how crappy
this guy is how he screwed up everything
you need to love her and her grief and
her pain
and then you need to have your grief
somewhere else
okay okay
and
your grief is less at him you're rage
pissed off at him and you should be
idiot he screwed up everything
broke the law
but more so
this is really inconvenient
this blew up a picture of a good family
we had a we had a deal about how
christmas was gonna go and this idiot
screwed it up
and now y'all are left picking up the
pieces right
yes yes so i want you to grieve
the lost picture more than i want you to
sit around being pissed off at him
you sitting around being pissed off at
him is just poisoning yourself hoping he
gets more in jail and he won't he's
already in jail
that ship sailed
every moment you waste being angry at
him
it's just a moment i'm you're kind of
choosing to live a little bit shorter
life
because your body stress chemicals are
dealing with you not him
right
and then grieving the picture is
sucks
like man we thought i was gonna look
like this and it's not all grief is is
the gap between what i hoped for and
what i thought was gonna happen and what
reality is
and that's where you're sitting right
now
and i hate it for you
it's heartbreaking
but we often take our rage and we
wallpaper over our grief with it
and then we just die young or we get
addicted to crap
oh no thanks yeah exactly so just go sit
in the grief
and that might be writing a letter to
him that you're never gonna send him
that might be
writing a letter to dear christmas
here's how you are gonna look and i know
that sounds so lame but there's
something
physiological about it and hyper
psychologically cathartic about it
writing a letter to christmas dear
christmas you were gonna look like this
we were gonna have a tree
and tom and rick were gonna be sitting
around and there are gonna be kids
everywhere and it's gonna smell like
this
and now we're not
and there's a here's what we're doing
and this sounds bananas i know you are
linking
for i'm gonna simplify neurology here
neuroscience you're linking your
amygdala to your frontal lobe
you're letting that part of your brain
that is spinning out trying to solve for
chaos know
that your brain is back in control of
things
and it will go ah cool
what's next
and then you can decide all right what
is christmas going to look like now
and then it becomes
a a how are we going to plan it and then
when christmas shows up you're going to
be sad
i'm and i'm just using christmas right
this will be every birthday this will be
every family get together this will be
your sunday luncheons whatever it looks
like you'll be sad because there's an
empty seat over there
and that stinks
and it's okay to be safe how do i just
listen to
like i don't even know what to say to my
sister or to her kids when it comes up
like i just kind of sit there like a
lump on a log because i don't know what
to say so one of the greatest things you
can offer somebody else in their grief
is your presence not your words
okay just showing up is important
and when they say things like i can't
believe my daddy did this he embarrassed
me whatever the conversation is your
response is i'm so sorry you're hurting
i'm so sorry that your heart's broken
nothing to do with him forget that guy
he's done his damage his appeared at the
end of his sentence
it's about their hurt in the present
okay
and
if they invite you in to solutions
then you offer
well what if we do christmas then you
start talking about solutions
but let them invite you in and it takes
the pressure off of you you don't have
to perform you just got to show up and
be with
and bring tacos
[Laughter]
bring food and just sit
there's a lot of grief that happens
underneath a blanket next to your sister
watching the office for the 40th time
eating chips and salsa
terrible dietary choice not good for you
but we're just we're in this together or
we're gonna go for a walk
we're just gonna go for a walk around
the neighborhood
and okay here's here's a good boundary
if she's ranting and raving about her
husband
there does come a moment when you say
you get five five minutes and then we're
not talking about him anymore
and you will get to model for her what a
boundary can look like in this situation
and it will be a gift to her
because right now everything in her life
is consumed with this guy this guy this
guy this guy this guy and which because
he's a threat her brain is searching for
threats he's a bear and her her brain is
trying to solve for the bear
and what you can do by saying all right
you get five minutes and then we're
gonna go for a walk five minutes and
then we're gonna sit down and map out
what thanksgiving's gonna look like
she gets to go ah bear and then
back to problem solving
okay it's and now what
and most of us get stuck in the and now
what and we try to go back and edit
sentences that have already been written
in our lives and the world is begging us
to write something like
what are you right next what's gonna
happen next
right well yeah i've just the past three
years of it has just seemed like we just
keep waiting for yes the next worst
thing so the shoe dropped what whammo
yeah
and just given the nature of my job
there's always another shoe right but
always always another shoe but
um you can't i mean you can't live like
that
no so i'll give you a um a piece of
advice that my buddy todd gave me
um he's a finance guy you may have heard
me say this on the show
i mean
i get set off from
fiscal trump like it's all coming down
we're going to be trading cigarettes and
coffee and soil you know that kind of
stuff
and one day he's a finance guy he works
for the
he he's brilliant and i was just
peppering him with questions so what
about this and what about that what
about that and then if this happens then
that's gonna happen and they're gonna
call this and
and here's what he told me and i loved
it and i used it all the time now
he said john i don't have a meteorite
plan
if we're just driving along and a
meteorite hits us i'm going to deal with
that when it happens
and that one sentence has rattle i don't
have a
what if an army rolls on my driveway
i'll solve that problem when it happens
because it's not going to happen and if
it does
and i know there's people like no bro
you got to be prepared to get okay cool
great now i've got lots of deep freezers
and i got meat for a year i'm still a
prepper a little bit
but
like i don't have a meteorite plan so if
the mob shows up in six months
the mob shows up in six months let's
plan thanksgiving
let's start exercising let's you and
your sister start a yoga class and just
start going
let you have weekly
ice cream with the kids we don't talk
about dad we talk about school and girls
and boys and gross stuff and ew you kiss
somebody like we're gonna go there
just a weekly breakfast with aunt marie
whatever
or sunday lunch at marie's house
you get four minutes to talk about
husband and then then ah no more we're
not talking about that we're talking
about today we're talking about tomorrow
we're gonna talk about thanksgiving
we're gonna talk about christmas we're
gonna talk about your birthday whatever
summer vacation
and then if a meteorite hits we will
deal with the meteorite then if another
shoe comes flying through this this
house great we'll do it then
and i love love love your heart marie so
great gosh your sister's so lucky to
have you awesome awesome
you're making my my
heart about humanity feel better
one person at a time marie
don't need to say the right things just
show up with tacos and a half bottle of
wine or something
and just say
i hate that
so sorry
man what a gift
all right as we wrap up today's show
oh yikes
the song's a little bit on the nose sort
of i don't mean for it to be so
everybody palette cleanser off the take
off your pants and jacket album blink182
the songs stay together for the kids
not really applicable to this last call
it's just a song
it goes like this
it's hard to wake up when the shades
have been pulled shut this house is
haunted it's so pathetic and it makes no
sense at all
and i'm ripe with things to say and the
words rotten fall away what stupid poem
could fix this home
i'd read it every day
so here's your holiday hope you enjoy it
this time you gave it all away and it
was mine so when you're dead and gone
will you remember this night 20 years
now lost
it's not right
actually it's like that last call it's
not right
i'm sorry y'all are going through this
and the question we all have to ask
ourselves is
now what
right here on the dr john dolone's show
[Music]